yeah
弔電って整って悠樹がぁあいうえ美味しい
幽霊に愛されてこそそのようなあー
たとえこの身が口あってのと思う俺は言えとそこにここに下すことにしました
肇社長です皆様系生えてますか
僕も生えてますよちょびっガンマン気がしてるんだと筆ビット生えてるんですけど僕
ですねレーザー脱毛に行ったことがありまして
僕そんなめちゃくちゃ対応が声わけではないんですけども試しに
レーザー脱毛に行ったんですよマジで痛い女性の方でよくレーザーなどもする人いると
思うんですけども
あー音誤植がかなり気合いが入るぞ男の指示とかはため恋から多分全然女の人に行き
たいと思うんですけどやばいですよ
レーザー脱毛は本当にますやたないと耐えられないくらいの痛みなんですけども
僕は
まず言ったことがありません
[音楽]
というわけで食べ男も女もね体の気というものを気にする人がいると思うんですけど
もう今回これもナビつきました
ヒカリエスってありこれは何やらですね光を使ってね脱毛する何かでございます光を
当ててなんか脱毛して bs らしいんですけどもうこれねここにもある通りですね花
の色が結構か気になってまして
恋お肌には対応
してないんですよなぜかというとレーザー脱毛も同じなんですけどもあの脱毛っていう
のはですねう黒いものに反応してそのくらいものにレーザーを照射して焼き殺すんだと
思います適当に言いました信じないでくださいねわからないんですけど多分おおよそ
そんな感じじゃないかと思います
これもたぶんを同様に花理由と比べてき白いじゃないですかね花を傷めずに黒い子
木の部分だけぱちんぱちんぱちん光を当ててプロしていくっていうのがヴェーザーだ妻
なんですよでホストでレーザー脱毛までいっぱい体験してほしい
もうなんか経営を起こしながらやってたらしいです僕はうわー選手はこれやばい長綱
まあすぐ prism プリズム spect グラムって感じですねイヤーのなんか
ねレーザー脱毛の痛みだねあの言葉で表すと
説明はすごい
輪ゴムで軽く弾かれてどうですみたいな感じなんですけど実際は何度なら鮮度に熱した
書き初めの紙を止めるあの文鎮の部分でここを一緒に十手されるみたいな感じですそれ
は全身あると言う
本当に痛かったからねぇどうしても気が気になる子といったを説明します
マジで一切入ってこなくなるんだよ僕は途中で出すとしたんでまだちょっと入れます
これで電源を
もう始まっているこういうことはなんかメイドが目指す隠さなくていいの人は好きだと
いうらしいですねぇ
渦の毛を剃って
でここに多分光は出ていくんだと思いますけど何も分かりません
うわぁ
yeah
ナンディ
ペンだことなっているもうちょっといるぶっぱねぇよ
メジャー ba 7ミカにすごい目がやばかった今
はっはぁんっ yeah なるほどこうなりたいよこれ
待ってでは思い出す
ってユーザーだと思いためよハァハァハズレか見たい
畦めっちゃあの世はいす2台ではすんだ
まぁまぁまぁこんなもんかあのですねこれあの多分出力圧出力的には食べるその
レーダーカヴェンさんなくてもなく日は目の出力で設置してるんでそんな厚揚げ仰い
でる方がたぜていたいので追っちゃうみんな
何でもされるほどと思いますこれあればもっと痛い関学病院で受ける事態のレーザーだ
と思うんです
市販でもできる脱毛器具っていうのは実にいろいろあるんですけども
最初で説明したとおりこれは黒いものに反応しますなんでまた僕の空にこうやって罰ん
だったら僕は全身もいます今でこの性能を生かしてですね黒い部分が多くなった羽根
だぉね脱帽してみようと思います黒い
部分が出てきている手がスポットのところでね麻雀っていうのはまあ毛が生えてません
しかといって中には繊維が詰まっています黒い部分とかに反応して光を当てて脱毛する
と話しバナナどうなるのか扱ったら寝ようとしたらホットバナナになってあの美味しく
なるかもしれませんじゃあさっそくちょっと鼻を断つもしてみようと思います
なんでこんなことを思いついたんだろうずうにですねどうなるのかなって思いました
黒いところにして反応しませんからねパンダが2つ申します
何が起きている特に何もちょっとなんかいないといいますか
[音楽]
パンティけど何回かやってみたんですけども焦げ臭い
感情する果たせた髪はどうなってるのでしょうか開けていきましょう
ああんにも演歌がありませんでした
yeah
me
[音楽]
パパッ
パワーが多分ねちょっと痛んだ気がします多分漫談地帯が白いから果たせなかったん
ですけども学んだのカバーが黒かったから反応したみたいでございます病院たが強く
なっちゃう奴だったらホントにマジ超痛いですこれは痛かったですからねまあなら脱毛
しても周りが守ってくれるので味は落ちることがありませんでした
よかったですね手で皆さんレーザー脱毛本当にいいたいので
て行く方はぜひ覚悟して行ってみてくださいじゃん
パ